what would be your advice because you're
obviously introvert would you say yeah
what would be your advice for somebody
who's also an introvert and and has has
a problem kind of breaking out of their
shell
in terms of maybe like wanting to be in
the music industry or just wanting to
kind of like be in an industry in which
it can be a little bit harder being an
introvert
I would say uh you know just to remember
that like if you're comfortable like
you're not not growing at all so it's
just like same with the gym like
you got to be uncomfortable to like
really grow so like you wanna I always
try to try to stay just beyond your
comfort zone you know I mean if you
realize that you're super comfortable
you're not in the right place then like
just try to like go a little bit take a
couple steps further you know what I
mean